foreign
Philadelphia where you're born and
raised and the playground is where you
spent most of your days what's up dude
hey how you doing good hey I need you I
need you to I need you to rescue me here
what's up
um I guess I just had a question um
listen I've been sexting a lot and I
just want to know if that's cheated that
would be incredible but
hopefully that's not what you're asking
what's up that's not me
um my question is so I'm a 27 year old
man I'm still trying to figure out you
know my life together just you know with
career and stuff
um but I ended up meeting a girl
um and it as far as my past relationship
she's a walking green flag like
everything about her is just great
uh but the issue that I'm having is the
walking green flag
it's a good way to put it um and she's
great she's super super cool super funny
super cute like everything is just
everything's great but the issue is that
uh she has a kid and
that's kind of where I wanted to speak
with you about it because I need some
help I need some advice here
what disqualifies an amazing woman
from being amazing just because she has
a child
my thing is that that's why I kind of
want to mention like I said I'm 27 I'm
still trying to figure out my life
um and that's where it's like you know
that's something that it's just
I don't picture get to it you are
circling the wagons homie just get to it
and here's the deal when you say it out
loud you know you're gonna sound bad
just say it anyway let's get to it
for uh break up with it right now break
up with her right now
break up with it right now
because this amazing woman doesn't come
without her kid in fact she'd be a
terrible human being if she ditched her
kid for you
and you don't want to be a dad cool
she's not the one for you right now
have enough decency and enough
respect for you for her for that sweet
little kid of hers to call it
and to have the Integrity to say
everything about you I love I am not
ready to be a dad
look at that that's the thing it's like
I'm not I'm not a hundred percent
against it and that's kind of you have
to be a thousand percent for it
you can't partly be in in a parenting
role
and I get that it's all all all in
and I've got a buddy I was I was out on
a hunt trip the other day with a buddy
in the middle of the the frozen tundra
up north who married somebody adopted
um
uh her son right away
and years later their relationship's
amazing he's an amazing dad he he's
always been with with I mean he's always
been
um married to her and a dad that's how
they start the relationship and it's
awesome and and it's hard it had some
complexities there's some challenges
along the way no question about it
but you want both
you want her you want a fantasy version
of her
and that person isn't real and when we
project fantasies onto other people it
ends in Ash and a lot of broken hearts
and this time there's a kid don't do
that
and I and that's kind of why I wanted to
speak with you about it because I kind
of wanted like you said like it's hard
like I kind of wanted to
I I have no idea what it would be like
because like we're still very new like
we're not even dating yet like we've
just been going out on dates but you
know we've been clicking very hard where
um we've been seeing each other a lot
and she's super like understanding she's
like she tells me at any point if it
gets too much with like her custody
schedule or anything like that like she
will be willing to she understands if I
can't do it like I said to you like I'm
not 100 against it I just like I have
never seen myself in this position
before so I kind of want to see like
what is the
what I am signing myself up for if I do
do this because like I obviously have no
idea
I don't think any parent who has kids or
adopts kids fully knows what they're
signing up for until they're all in
because if we did we'd probably there'd
be moments when we
we opted out that's that's that's the
that's the deal
right
that's the deal and so
again you won't have a tryout period you
want to practice
and that's not fair to her and it's not
fair to that kid
I think I I hundred percent I mean I get
that you this is not how you drew it up
right you were gonna meet somebody and
then you're gonna fall in love and
you're gonna be married for seven or
eight years then you might have a kid or
like I I get that or I'm never gonna
have a kid I have no interesting kid
um that totally makes sense that's the
same as I fell in love with somebody and
then we ended up moving into Nebraska
I'd never had that plan I thought we're
gonna live in New York City for that
life happens that way that's okay
where it's not okay is when you fully
understand oh I didn't expect this and
here it is
and I only want part of this
then you got to let the rest go you
gotta let all of it go or you gotta say
I'm a hundred percent in
I get that
what'd you think I was gonna say because
you don't like my answer what'd you
think I was going to say no I don't I
don't I don't have a problem with your
answer it's because I like I said I I
I'm 27 so all my friends are the same
age as me and none of them have ever
dealt with this so it's like when I talk
to somebody about it
they give me the you know what are your
friends telling you
um well my closest friends like oh I
guess so see you as a step dad like they
make a joke out of it but uh
um
obviously it's a big Challenge and they
all say they couldn't do it
um
with me like I said I'm not against it
I'm not 100 against it like I'm not I
have not
when we first started it was a it was a
fling we both like had we talked to each
other we both were just like we are not
looking for anything serious but
we immediately clicked and so I knew
from the start that she had a kid and
um and you hooked up with her anyway and
here you are
yes yes
so either you're gonna have to break
somebody's heart
are you gonna have to choose to grow up
either way you've got a path that you
weren't expecting
absolutely
let me say if you choose to get serious
with her
you have to understand that her kid will
come first the kid has to come first
and you've got to know that
yeah I 100 know that and you've got and
not only know that but there has to be
not only okay with you that's gotta be
awesome because that's the way it should
be
right right
I've watched plenty of videos lots of
read articles like I I've I'm fully
understanding of
that part absolutely and you're gonna
have to make peace with her ex whether
that was a fling or they were married
before whatever
because that dude's gonna be part of
your life forever
yeah
just is and I've seen it done in so
incredibly well
like dads like
like go out and check in with each other
what are you seeing with our kid like
basically dads they're like hey man we
got two sets of eyes on this on this kid
this kid's gonna get double love from us
and I've seen it handled so immaturely
that you would think there were middle
schoolers involved they're so dumb it's
my toys I'm taking my trucks and going
home it's just so lame so if you're in
call the dude and ask him out for dinner
and say I'm gonna be a part of this
woman's life I love this woman I want to
honor your kid till the end of time
tell me what you're seeing tell me about
your boy tell me about what you want to
see like invite him in and if he chooses
to act like a middle school or you can't
think about it
but at least you will take the high road
and see like I'm trying to paint a
picture for you dude I I would not
discount a single mom for anything
okay like there's nothing that
disqualifies her from being amazing and
awesome the question is do you want to
be a dad
right now
and if you don't
walk away man
and if you do be all all in
all right yeah that makes sense
and quit asking your bodies dude they
don't they don't they don't know man
that's why I wanted to speak with you
because I was like somebody that I
actually like I listen to you all the
time so I was like I trust I trust your
opinion enough if I could just give you
a call I appreciate that I appreciate
that I man I I wish you the best
whatever and so number one make sure you
do this don't don't read the YouTube
comments on this because you're gonna
get all kinds of people throwing
grenades and all so just don't do that
the second is
I'm not going to fault you for not
wanting to be a dad at 27.
cool
where I will fault you is if you drag
this poor woman through it because y'all
keep hooking up
or if you kind of like hanging out with
her but you don't see a future to for it
but in some shape form or fashion you
lead her to believe that there is a
future
that's just cruel man don't do that
don't do that and that's not just a
single women that's with any women
and women that's any like that's with
anybody you're romantically attracted to
just don't do that just don't do that
but man she sounds awesome
she's a walking green flag I've never
heard that that sounds like he's got
some kind of illness but I'm gonna trust
you that that means it's awesome
um
I don't know man got a hard decision to
make
just be a person of character integrity
when you make it